for the Oscars last night I did yeah did
you folks see the Oscars pretty good
yeah Oscars go I thought so coupla sir
but some people said oh I don't know not
20 there was a couple of surprises right
yeah 1917 was predicted to win Best
Picture last night and it didn't yeah
yeah the producer was furious and said
we've fought World War one for nothing
and of course it lost because this is
this is a huge news parasite one yeah it
won four Academy I don't know why my
voice core one for gosh gosh I'm dog
milk in the cow and it won four awards
so stupid I think maybe puberty's
finally family yeah yeah finally I knew
I knew I knew it would come now know the
Oscars was the film it was a parasite
and it won four Academy Awards including
Best International Film and Best Picture
and yeah it was really are you from
Korea you're not you're not from ku
you're just happy for Korea
oh yeah I just said okay so you're you
are descended from Koreans yes okay so I
so I see you were just being real
sticklers about no work three in we're
not from Kris so you're happy for your
country yes okay I'm glad we spent I
think half an hour clearing that
well we're happy for your country too
but guess what not everybody is happy
yeah apparently I'm telling you I'm
telling you apparently there was a film
from North Korea that got no did you
know this there's a film from North
Korea that got no Oscar attention
everyone in North Korea was really
rooting for it and it was inexplicably
overlooked and I thought and it just got
no attention and I thought just to be
fair to North Korea I would maybe show
the trailer tonight
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you